bonsoir tout le monde je m'appelle
krystel est aujourd'hui offert ma
présentation une solution à portée de
main qui parler vous ne serez pas
découvrir une cure pour le diabète les
maladies du coeur le cancer
malheureusement je ne suis pas une de
ces génies qui a trouvé un moyen
efficace peu coûteux et écologique pour
traiter ces maladies qui peuvent être
mortels par contre j'aimerais vous
proposer un moyen de prévention contre
ces maladies
il est là tranquille dans ma poche tout
petit tout frais mais drôlement efficace
vous aimeriez le voir évidemment pas
tout vous n'avez qu'à patienter un peu
plus longtemps
vous vous demandez sûrement comment j'ai
trouvé ma solution
et bien si vous ne le saviez pas déjà
je fais partie de la génération z celle
des branches et ma génération est née
avec un accès facile rapide et directe à
tout ce qui se passe autour de nous donc
contrairement à ce que vous pourriez
croire les cellulaires nous apporte
beaucoup plus que la distraction
ces outils peuvent nous permettre de
devenir des êtres plus brillant plus
instruits c'est d'ailleurs à l'oeil de
la panoplie de renseignements
scientifiques tad qui est à la portée de
nos mains grâce aux cellulaire que j'ai
trouvé comment nous pourrions résoudre
plusieurs graves problèmes de santé
avant même qu'il n'émerge
je vous présente un gros zaba oui c'est
petit objet que vous utilisez une ou
deux fois par jour que prévenir les
maladies aussi graves que le cancer
mais est il normal en 2018 tue près de
2.5 milliards de personnes soit environ
36 % de la population mondiale n'est pas
de brosse à dents est ce que vous
comprenez que cela veut dire que plus de
personnes possèdent un téléphone
cellulaire qui ne brosse à dents
justement prenons le temps de comparer
notre monde à celui de nos voisins plus
éloignées il est facile de voir une
différence dans l'épreuve
utilisée pour l'hygiène dentaire voici
les brosses à dents auquel nous sommes
habitués
vous voyez tous quelque chose de
familier si vous le voulez bien
regardons maintenant les brosses à dents
de nos voisins qui malgré leur peu de
moyens vont essayer de se brosser les
dents
tous les jours elles sont en effet plus
écologique
mais je crains que cette brindille et se
doit ne soit pas hygiénique
nos voisins sont ils heureux avec leurs
besoins écologiques
certes le sourire est là toutefois je
crains qu'il ne soit pas tout à fait le
même que le nôtre
l'analyse de tout ça deux méthodes de
résultats or pas c'est bien cela méthode
utilisée est est la même partout
c'est à dire offrir à tous livrent à
sanaa cela réduirait considérablement
les risques de développer certaines
maladies et nous aiderait à sauver
beaucoup d'argent en effet regardons les
chiffres
avez vous déjà comparé le prix moyen
d'une brosse à dents au prix moyen d'une
série de traitements de chimiothérapie
pour une seule personne
nous préférons tous deux loin et paye et
l'unis 93 dollars canadiens prix moyen
mondial en gros ça va que les 65 mille
dollars canadiens pour un traitement
contre un cancer causé en partie par une
mauvaise hygiène dentaire mais comprenez
vous réellement la nécessité d'investir
ce montant dans une brosse à dents de
qualité et de bien juger
spontanément vous me répondrez que c'est
pour éviter les caries ce qui n'est pas
faux mais aller ou deux au delà de cela
logiquement tout ce qui entre dans notre
corps passe par la bouche n'est ce pas
alors cela en fait un lieu idéal pour le
commencement de la propagation de
certaines maladies et plusieurs études
ont démontré que notre santé générale
semblerait reposer sur une bonne hygiène
dentaire
c'est pour cette raison qu'il est
important en premier lieu de se
débarrasser de la plaque qui se forment
continuellement son moment si ce n'est
pas fait vous serez atteindre de
gingivite puis si cette maladie des
gencives continue de s'aggraver
vous serez atteint de parodontite qui
atteint davantage les eaux et les dessus
de la bouche
c'est à partir de ce moment que vous
serez beaucoup plus à risque face aux
maladies plus graves mais vous demandez
sûrement comment faire pour que tout le
monde a sa propre boîte à idées
plusieurs solutions sont offertes
j'en ai trouvé son facile en effet à
réaliser premièrement lors de voyages
humanitaires de 15 ans les participants
ou vacanciers pour un chacun a apporté
quelques brosse à dents pour les
distribuer aux gens dans le besoin ou
les laisser avec le pouls bord de la
femme de ménage dans la chambre d'hôtel
en plus il ne remet pas besoin
d'apporter de dentifrice l'essentiel
c'est de pouvoir se débarrasser
efficacement dans la plaque d'une option
créer des campagnes de financement sur
internet
je suis sûr d'une campagne de
financement qui aiderait à acheter des
brosses à dents qui préviendrait des
maladies dangereuses serait fructueuse
et autres options développer et diffuser
plus de vidéos sur de grandes
plateformes comme youtube qui
expliquerait la nécessité de se brosser
les dents et comment bien c'est libre
c'est comme de plus les organisations
humanitaires comme la croix rouge le
croissant rouge ainsi que l'oni pourrait
elle aussi est distribué des brosses à
dents dans les camps de réfugiés ou
lorsqu'elles partent en mission
finalement les compagnies de produits
dentaires comme oral b goguette et gones
pourraient faire des promotions
spéciales comme acheter de nouveaux
radars
nous emmènerons une à une personne dans
le besoin voyons maintenant comment il
est possible de régler un problème à
partant de sa source
les solutions à portée de main existe la
mienne en est la preuve
lorsqu'on y pense bien une bretonne ar
coup de pub mais elle peut valoir une
vie humaine
[Applaudissements]